so sah die abstimmung nach meinem
letzten video zum thema tipp auf n tv.de
aus tipp ist quasi jetzt schon abgelehnt
13 prozent zustimmung das bedeutet mit
98 7 prozent abgelehnt
bei diesem ersten pro und contra video
hat mich ein kommentar besonders
beschäftigt fanny wird 96 hat mehr
ausgewogenheit gewünscht also ich hätte
mich immer bieten können aber beim
heutigen thema wird es auf jeden fall
mehr pro und auch eine menge contra
geben unsere
bundesverteidigungsministerium ursula
von der leyen steht im verdacht bei
ihrer doktorarbeit abgeschrieben zu
haben und sie soll sogar illegale
menschen versuche dafür gemacht haben
klick zum procontra
das ist ein haar apropos verbotene
menschen versuche für die doktorarbeit
der deutschen verteidigungsministerin
ursula von der leyen
die süddeutsche zeitung hat das
berichtet und es scheint nicht ganz von
der hand zu weisen zu sein ihre
doktorarbeit handelt von frauen die
während der geburt mit vorzeitig
geplatzter fruchtblase ein warmes bad
nehmen
damals wurde das als gefährlich
angesehen und normalerweise nicht
gemacht ursula von der leyen hat aber
genau das untersucht und so der vorwurf
die frauen nicht über das potenzielle
risiko aufgeklärt das wären menschen
versuche dafür bräuchte man die
einwilligung der patientin und eine
ethik kommission müsste dem zustimmen
beides scheint nicht erfolg zu sein
es ist ganz klar davon allein hätte hier
womöglich gegen wichtige
wissenschaftliche grundsätze verstoßen
und wenn sich der verdacht erhärtet die
gesundheit der ungeborenen kinder
potenziell gefährdet eine infektion kann
in diesem stadium für das kind tödlich
sein
das wäre ein unding und dinge gar nicht
aber es gibt noch die andere seite der
medaille ethikkommission waren damals
noch gar nicht überall üblich dass gibt
nämlich der professor für medizinethik
an der uni heidelberg wolfgang egger zu
bedenken er plädiert für milde
also was nun ist das päpstlicher als der
papst wenn hier auf grundsätze bestanden
wird die schon damals galten aber nicht
überall beachtet wurden oder sollte man
hier immer auch den zeitgeist beachten
dass das wirklich damals praktiziert
wurde
genau das ist auch die frage beim
vorwurf des plagiats also der vorwurf
dass sie abgeschrieben hätte 43 5 des
haupt teils der von ursula von der leyen
geschriebenen doktorarbeit seien nicht
völlig korrekt verfasst worden also
verdacht auf plagiat im 62 seitigen
hauptteil der dissertation würden sich
auf 27 seiten abgeschriebene inhalte
wiederfinden
fünf seiten würden sogar ein plagiats
anteil von 75 bis 100 prozent 3 einen
von 50 bis 70 prozent und 19
einen plagiats anteil von mehr als 0 bis
50 prozent aufweisen all diese zahlen
wurden von der website vroniplag
veröffentlicht karl theodor zu
guttenberg an ethischer waren und
silvana koch mehrin in allen wurde
vorgeworfen bei ihrer doktorarbeit
abgeschrieben zu haben sie alle bekamen
ihre doktortitel aberkannt und auch bei
ursula von der leyen ist der vorwurf nur
schwer von der hand zu weisen
die seite vroniplag ist so ein bisschen
wie die seite wikileaks nur eben für die
situation also doktorarbeiten und es
sind keineswegs aktivisten wie ursula
von der leyen sie titulierte sondern
professoren und wissenschaftler sie
durchforschen jede menge doktorarbeit
und prüfen diese auch fällt schlecht
gemachte quellenangaben und zitate im
fall von der leyen ging es um ihre
doktorarbeit mit dem titel c reaktives
protein als diagnostischer parameter zur
erfassung eines am leon infektions
syndroms bei vorzeitigen blasensprung
und therapeutischen entspannungsbad in
der geburtsvorbereitung im job da habe
ich keine fehler gemacht
ehrlich gesagt geht es um zitat kommt es
zum blasensprung bevor die wehen
einsetzten oder bevor die 38
schwangerschaftswoche erreicht ist
müssen erste schnell zwei mögliche fälle
unterscheiden passiert dass aufgrund
einer infektion dann ist eile geboten
möglicherweise auch ein kaiserschnitt
liegt keine infektion vor
dann kann die frau eine normale geburt
erleben eventuell auch in einer
geburtstag wie in der arbeit beschrieben
so frank louwen von der uni frankfurt
unserer von der leyen hat sich mit
diesem thema beschäftigt und das sogar
ziemlich erfolgreich noch ein zitat die
arbeit war damals inhaltlich neu und
relevant das ergebnis der doktorarbeit
ist sogar in die leitlinien aufgenommen
worden berichtet frank laufen
aber und das ist der punkt sie hat
offensichtlich nicht korrekt zitiert das
ist in der wissenschaft ein
schwerverbrechen geht es danach und hat
unserer wunderland wirklich in diesem
umfang abgeschrieben und die
entsprechenden stellen nicht als zitat
gekennzeichnet dann muss ihr der
doktortitel aberkannt werden punkt
denk ich an deutschland in der nacht bin
ich um den schlaf gebracht ich sehe
schon unzählige doktoren der medizin in
deutschland vor dem ende ihrer
wissenschaftlichen laufbahn in schimpf
und schande aus den krankenhäusern
praxen und unis gejagt weil ihre
doktorarbeiten einfach nicht
wissenschaftlichen standards entsprechen
das ist nun wirklich eigentlich nichts
neues dass doktorarbeiten im
medizinischen bereich nicht unbedingt
das niveau anderer fachbereiche
erreichen
meistens sind sie relativ dünn und
kommen so gerade mal auf 100 seiten
werden ansonsten so drei bis vierhundert
seiten als erstrebenswert gelten und die
themen also dann macht ja nahezu jeder
dr
und dann sucht man sich irgendwie da
saugt man sich die themen aus den
fingern und das noch niemand über
rektale zahn-op es also zahn operationen
durch den hintern geschrieben hat ist
quasi ein wunder fast jeder mediziner
es schreibt eine doktorarbeit da müssen
die themen eben schon speziell sein
entspricht die doktorarbeit von ursula
von der leyen also dem standard oder ist
sie aufgrund ihrer relevanz sogar noch
besser dann der es eigentlich extrem
ungerecht ihr den doktortitel
abzuerkennen
andererseits standard sind standards
basta es kann doch nicht jeder das
möglichst dünnste brett bohren eine
klandestine ein fremdwort jetzt habe ich
zeit schreiben also das heißt so viel
wie einvernehmlich geheim verschwiegen
so ein bisschen konservativ also eine
heimliche vereinbarung in einem
studiengang das doktorarbeiten eben
nicht so den wissenschaftlichen
standards unbedingt genügen müssen und
dass man da mal ein oder zwei augen
zudrückt ist einfach ungültig und wer an
einem solchen system teilnehmen
der oder die macht sich trotzdem
schuldig und muskel strafen selbst wenn
er oder sie keine ahnung davon gehabt
hat unwissenheit schützt vor strafe
nicht
ja das ist die andere seite der medaille
was meint ihr
bei mir schlagen zwei seelen ach in
meiner brust diskutiertes auf n tv.de
dort könnt ihr auch boten und so können
wir uns dann ein meinungsbild machen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes sie haben
anfang des videos gesehen der link ist
hier oben und da geht es auch zum
letzten pro und contra video zum thema
tipp einfach draufklicken einfach
draufklicken jetzt aber bis dann bleibt
dran